there is outrage over a new video of a
journalist detained in belarus now it
comes nearly two weeks after he was
pulled off of a plane
and arrested state television in belarus
broadcast a very emotional interview in
which roman protozavitch confesses
to organizing the riots his supporters
say that he made these comments under
duress
or even torture as holly williams
reports he appears to have wounds on his
wrist
and at times echoed government
statements
it's this immunity i never want to get
involved in politics again
said a tearful roman protesevic in a
90-minute video on belarusian state tv
part of a forced confession according to
his friends and family
coerced by the regime of president
alexander lukashenko
he's a close ally of russian president
vladimir putin
who's ruled belarus with an iron fist
for more than
26 years in the video protosavic
admitted to trying to
topple the president apparently a
reference to demonstrations last year
after lukashenko claimed to have won
nearly 80
of the vote in an election widely
considered a
sham proto-savic was flying from athens
to lithuania last month
when belarusian authorities forced the
plane to redirect to their capital
claiming a bomb threat thought to be an
excuse to arrest the dissident
and condemned by president biden as
shameful
protesters supporters claim wounds on
his wrists
suggest he's been tortured his father
dimitri says his son has been
broken and nobody should believe the
confession
if convicted roman protest faces a
prison term of up to
15 years for organizing mass unrest
but when he was taken from the plane
other passengers reportedly heard him
say
quote i'll get the death penalty here
anthony thanks holly williams in london
that video is so
upsetting to watch chilling yeah
absolutely upsetting
you can see the duress you can see the
pain it's very very frightening